Loki you are charged with escaping from your
timeline how do you plead a god doesn't plead
now hang on just a minute our timeline is
in chaos we need loki trusting this man is
not a good idea you cross me there
are deadly consequences go for it
do I get a weapon gear up ah i don't know
absolutely not now streaming only of disneyplus
Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my marvel loki episode 1 early review video
there's so much stuff going on in the marvel
cinematic universe i feel like loki is probably
going to wind up being everyone's favorite series
so far i will be doing videos for all the episodes
so be sure to subscribe to get everything if
you're brand new to the channel and we're doing
a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter that is just be a subscriber
and let me know what you're most excited to see
on loki i will compare loki with Wandavision
and falcon and winter soldier because this is the
third marvel disney plus series that we've gotten
so far and it is very different from the way they
made wanda vision and falcon and winter soldier
the character is obviously very different the
stuff that they're playing in is very different
but in the way that they use Wandavision to sort
of set up a couple other marvel movies and change
some really fundamental things about the mcu
they're doing the same thing with the loki
series but i'll explain why i think that loki is
doing a better job at that than the other series
did so far and also sort of playing into the idea
that people will be a little more satisfied with
what they did with the loki episodes but it should
come as no surprise to anyone that tom hiddleston
is fantastic as all these alternate versions of
loki so obviously we saw loki's story through the
mcu in the marvel movie so far up through avengers
infinity war where he truly achieved redemption
became a good character sacrificed himself and
then was killed by thanos we pick up with this
version of loki the varian in avengers endgame so
they kind of treat him like the trash version of
loki when they first haul him in because he's not
supposed to exist technically but because a lot of
the series is inspired by stuff like blade runner
rick and morty you have the tva recruiting him to
go after all these other alternate loki's because
someone that they can't track down is altering the
timeline in a fundamental way but when we talk
about the series affecting the plot of the rest
of the mcu pushing forward into marvel phase four
one of the ways they do that in the loki series
is that this mystery villain that they're going
after the reason why they recruit this variant
loki to take them down is because this mystery
villain is changing the entire timeline for
all the marvel characters so you talk about all
the big egglest avengers characters like thor
we're going to see in thor 11 thunder pretty
soon for doctor strange for scarlet witch so even
though you have scarlet witch in Wandavision doing
all these crazy things heading into doctor strange
too multiverse of madness causing even more
problems in the multiverse on a much bigger level
you have the loki series affecting everything as
it's happening before it's happened because we're
talking about affecting stuff that's happening in
the future as well so in the way that avengers end
game had that time travel plot where they go back
and you revisit moments from earlier marvel movies
the loki series does that as well and just like
during avengers end game they use those different
story lines like the thor plot to make thor the
dark world seem like a better movie in retrospect
like you go back and you watch sword of the dark
world now after watching all his scenes with his
mother in asgard and it seems like a much better
movie the loki series does the exact same thing
making some of the earlier especially marvel
phase one movies seem even better and obviously
because we're talking about loki they play mostly
on the thor movies but also on the avengers movies
as well because he's a big avengers character so
when we're talking about scope like you're looking
for a really big story this is a much bigger
story has potential to be a much bigger story
than Wandavision did even though there was a lot
of hype going into Wandavision early about what's
going on with the multiverse during this and you
have the whole evan peters quicksilver of it all
the loki series does things like that but i think
it just does a much better job of paying those
beats off like don't freak out worrying about
any kind of ralph boner type of twist on loki
but just in terms of big characters that it's
playing with i know he talked about this mystery
villain is fundamentally altering the mcu timeline
and they don't know who it is and they don't know
how to stop them and that's why they're recruiting
loki even though we obviously have not seen the
finale of loki yet early theory i think is pretty
easy to assume that it's not going to wind up
being king the conqueror even though the series is
playing in a lot of easter eggs for doctor strange
too multiverse of madness because it is marvel's
first legit multiverse series even though they
kind of teased that on Wandavision loki actually
does get into legit multiverse during episode 1 so
it will help set up the plot of doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness with some crossover
it'll also lead into ant-man 3 quantum mania
a little bit and there is a lot of king the
conqueror easter eggs in the background but i
think the only real role that he's going to play
in this series is that it's playing all of stories
that he is heavily involved in and will foreshadow
a lot of what he's doing when he does finally show
up during ant-man 3. but aside from potential big
post credit scenes in future marvel movies i'm
not expecting to see a lot of king the conqueror
during this series so when you're talking about
who's this big villain who's behind all these big
twists think more about characters that you'll
actually see show up during the loki series
like the other alternate versions of loki the
fundamental arc that loki is on during the series
though is one of self acceptance like the whole
idea in the mcu through his redemption through the
thor movies like thor ragnarok by the time we get
to avengers infinity war he finally accepts who
he is he calls himself an odin son that's kind of
what they're doing with the loki series so as he
goes around dealing with all these other variants
kind of like deckard goes around during blade
runner trying to take down the replicants loki
winds up learning more about himself and by the
finale finally winds up accepting who he is but
just in general the first episode does a lot of
what you would expect it to do it sort of serves
as an intro for the loki character again like if
you missed it previously on the big recap that you
see when a new season of a big serialized series
starts like if you missed the last 20 episodes in
the marvel cinematic universe these other movies
this is what just happened they even kind of
work that into the plot of the episode too owen
wilson's mobius character hauls him into the time
theater and sort of shows him the major events of
his life is sort of like a marvel recap of all the
big marvel movies like these are all the terrible
things that you've done or that you will do i know
there are a lot of questions about how the time
variance authority figures into the events of the
previous marvel movies like if they've been here
sitting at the end of time or sort of outside the
normal events of space time this would have been
like a pocket dimension outside of normal space
time why are they just making themselves known
now they answer a lot of those questions during
the first couple of episodes the show runner came
from rick and morty so he said that he was used
to people asking a lot of these really minutia
questions like he was anticipating people trying
to poke holes in a lot of the way that they use
time travel for instance so in the way that
they make the plots of a lot of the earlier
marvel movies seem better in retrospect with
the way they joke on them and reference them
during episodes they also make time travel seem a
lot better in the mcu the way they explain things
even though we haven't seen all the episodes yet
the showrunner did say that they were allowed
to go for whatever cameos they wanted so there
are way more cameos during the loki series than
there were during previous series so just keep
an eye out for that but just remember that we're
talking about loki here and they're mostly
dealing with a lot of what happened during
the thor movies his storyline which is mostly
specific to thor in some of the avengers movies
we've already seen him reference chris hemsworth's
thor heimdall in the previous trailers already so
just use that to calibrate your expectations but
if you didn't see some of my other loki videos
i did talk about the way the series is going to
handle chris hemsworth's thor just because most
of the time when you've seen loki in the previous
marvel movies he's either in a thor movie or he's
with thor or fighting thor in some way so thor has
just always been around when loki has been around
in one of the pitches for this series when
they came into it when they were pitching
tom hiddleston on it initially is that they were
asking the question what is going on with loki
when thor is not around all the time really good
example of that that sort of plays into the idea
of what happens during episode one at the end of
the first thor movie loki seemingly sacrifices
himself and he kind of gives up and just lets
himself be drawn into that wormhole like the
black hole as he's sucked into another place and
you just don't know what happens to him until he
shows up in the first avengers movie very similar
to what you see happen to loki during avengers end
game where he takes the tesseract portals away
and you kind of don't know what happens to him
until you pick up in the loki series so imagine
after the first thor movie if you'd actually
gotten a loki series where you see what happens
to loki the minute he gets sucked through that
black hole like you see him go and eventually
meet thanos make the bargain with him but as
i said tom hiddleston is fantastic as all these
disparate versions of loki like he's playing many
different versions of his character because you
have all these other variants but also the idea
that some of the alternate loki's would be played
by different actors owen wilson was also fantastic
as the mobius character he's sort of written to be
the deckard character in blade runner the sort of
hard-boiled detective that's trying to solve this
mystery about who it is which alternate version of
loki is fundamentally altering the timeline in
a way that they can't track Gugu Mbatha-Raw is
fantastic as her ravonna renslayer character
obviously a big kang the conqueror character
from the comics fantastic four in the thor comics
as well so i'll talk about those easter eggs when
i do the full episode videos you might recognize
wunmi mosaku from some other series she's playing
this main hunter that you see in all the trailers
the one that's basically giving loki the business
all the time the funny reference i'll make here
is if you remember that tv show night court
because the tva kind of is like a version of time
night court she's kind of like the raw's character
like the one that you don't want to mess with the
bailiffs will just wreck you if you look at them
the wrong way just in general i feel like they
did a really good job with casting the series
and i'll talk more about some of the other actors
like these other alternate versions of loki
played by different actors when they do show up in
episodes but sort of comparing this to Wandavision
falcon winter soldier because this is the third
marvel disney plus series that we've gotten so far
but whereas Wandavision was another series that
got super crazy like loki is getting super crazy
played with perspective at least for the first
several episodes you're meant to question scarlet
witch's sanity what's real what's fake what's she
creating on the fly who's the real villain here
the issue that i think a lot of people came away
from wanda vision with is that because of the way
the pandemic last year just shut everything down
they had to stop filming in the middle for a long
time they weren't able to get all the actors back
that they wanted for reshoots when it came time
to film the finale so there was all these great
ideas and deleted scenes that you hear about from
Wandavision concepts that they tried to do but for
a number of different reasons just weren't able to
get those in the final episodes so you wind up
with all this hype building through the first
half of the series and you don't really get the
payoff on Wandavision that you were expecting in
the finale the same thing also kind of happened
with the making of falcon and winter soldier
you probably heard about the whole deleted
subplot that they had to get rid of during
lockdown last year they were originally supposed
to air those episodes before wandavision and as a
result of all the big ideas and storylines they
had to get rid of and just the way they had to
cobble the series together it just didn't feel
like it was nearly as cool as it could have been
the difference with the loki series the really
good thing about the loki series is that it feels
like the first marvel disney plus series that
was not dramatically affected by the pandemic
like all the ideas they wanted to try made it into
the actual episodes i feel like the loki series
is probably going to wind up being most people's
favorite series so far just because of the tropes
that it plays in like i give Wandavision major
points for how it was able to pull off all the
different sitcom tropes and a lot of those
episodes and parodies were very nostalgic but
i was never a huge nick at knight fan and i did
watch a little bit of full house when i was a kid
and it was hilarious watching scarlet witch and
vision do all the marvel universe episodes through
that lens but it wasn't quite as rewarding as say
watching loki go full doctor who rick and morty
blade runner hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy like
if you give me a choice of which kind of episode
i'd want to see which genre i'd want to see them
do i pick sci-fi over sitcoms every single time
so just in general even if you're only a small
fan of the thor movies of the loki character i
think you're probably going to wind up digging the
loki series way more than the other marvel disney
plus series so far even though they didn't do a
lot of really good things on Wandavision falcon
and winter soldier just as a whole it feels like
loki is going to wind up being the better series
i know everyone has like a thousand questions
my full episode 1 easter egg video is going
to post on wednesday morning so make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel so
you don't miss that the episodes are about as
long as the falcon and winter soldier episodes
there is a bunch of other marvel stuff that's
happening this summer so i'll talk about that
in separate videos there's a whole bunch of new
black widow footage to just released so i'll try
to do that video next i'll name a new giveaway
winner when i post that video everyone click
here for my brand new thor 4 love and thunder
first look breakdown and click here for all my
other loki videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!